495
the attention was around the information
the internet was actually called the
information super highway it was about
looking up stuff it was a better
encyclopedia
look at this information
at the time in 1994 i don't think
anybody walking on earth understood that
the internet would eat up almost every
aspect of our lives everybody laughed at
me
in 1995 when i told them that i was
going to build a website to sell wine
and i'm telling you everybody laughed at
me
everybody said nobody's gonna buy i
remember being in meetings where people
would say
things like gary this is crazy nobody's
gonna buy wine on the internet the
internet is a fad
and
i would reply not only are people going
to buy wine on the internet people are
going to buy everything on the internet
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
as a matter of fact i used to use the
concept of people are going to buy
tomatoes on the internet because for
some reason people are very passionate
about touching tomatoes at the
supermarket
and that very much upset people and i
remember when when
fresh direct came to new york and people
were buying
tomatoes on the internet it was a very
big deal for me because i emailed a lot
of old friends and said i told you so
i think that
the blockchain
uh
in the consumer way that we're talking
about it with nfts is the biggest thing
that's happened since 1994 or 95 and i
think everybody here
should spend as many hours educating
themselves on what i'm really saying it
goes far beyond board ape or befriends
it is a monumental shift and right now
we're looking at
collectibility with a hint of utility
i think very quickly we're going to get
into a scaled world of utility with
hints of collectibility on the back end
and when that happens it's going to
start really moving what do you tell
somebody who
says i don't i don't really know about
nfts i don't know what that whole
world's about is it are they meaning the
people that say i don't know or the
people are saying it's a scam it's full
of [ __ ] it's a fad
i think the people who really just
haven't taken the time to look into it
or you know given it any thought at all
even if you don't invest or are involved
but know what it's about
i don't really
have a lot of passion of
really saying anything to them
meaning
i'm not
in any need of everybody
understanding it
it's going to happen anyway
what i would say to people i care about
is
it's a missed opportunity for you not to
get educated on this
but i
i often tell friends and family and
people i care about in my community
a very simple truth in moments like this
i have no interest in convincing anybody
on earth that this is important or
opportunistic
i have conviction
in my belief that it is
but i'm not in the commencing business
i'm in the business of putting things on
the record and being historically
correct
and this is an interesting point
and also being prepared
to have to deploy a lot of humility
if i'm historically incorrect
you know for me the reason i'm
comfortable doing this is if god forbid
because i don't want it to happen
this whole thing isn't real and
the blockchain
disappears i'm mentally prepared for
saying here's why i didn't see it this
happened and this happened and this
happened and i think that's a very
important part of many people's journeys
i think a lot of you here don't produce
content
or don't do things out of the fear of
being wrong and i want to remind you
that
being wrong
is not only okay it's actually a
preference it means you're pushing
what's not okay is when you're wrong not
being accountable and owning it
now obviously today we're at coders hq
how can coders or the coding community
or even like uh digital artists jump
onto the blockchain web 3.0
you know it's funny because a lot of you
probably are aware of my content i often
make fun of school or college
but what's unfortunate is that people
aren't really hearing what i'm saying i
believe that education is the most
important thing in the world
i think the way education is currently
being sold in the world has lost its way
in the reality of our world
the answer to your question is how do
you take advantage of it education
in december 2020 when i sensed through
my
strength which is consumer intuition
that the nft thing was finally getting
close
i spent hundreds of hours educating
myself
it started with very simple videos of
what is an nft today because i
remembered what i thought it was in 2017
when i first saw crypto kitties but i
knew that i hadn't been paying attention
so i had to re-educate myself
um
the answer is education like every web 2
developer in the world
should be learning how to develop for
web 3 because it's lucratively exciting
for them there's incredible demand for
web3 developers
and really it's not a very big leap for
a web 2 developer to get to web3 there's
just certain things you have to know and
understand that you know a decentralized
server is a very different environment
than owning your servers which is why so
many launches last year struggled
because a lot of developers
didn't remember that they were really
building on the blockchain they were so
accustomed to building on their own
server they got caught you could see the
traits uh so the answer to your question
is just education like put in the time
and effort to be educated
and another little side note
a lot of the energy right now in web 3
is unfortunately built around greed
and short-term financial behavior which
is a very different
game than web one and two were built on
because there wasn't this much money
being thrown around
so if you're in this room just make sure
that you're not getting clouded
by greed which what that really means is
once you have a hypothesis make sure
that your hypothesis is not grounded in
what you'd like to happen for you make
sure you're double checking everything
in a more holistic point of view on it
can you give any advice to coders who
want to capitalize on their code and
coding capability has there been any
like drive towards blockchain with 3.04
coders in specific i mean we know about
the nfts
well i mean you know any viable project
that's launching on its own website and
is minting a project needs development
you know some
you know yeah i have a lot of advice
it's called understand how to code on
decentralized servers
right it's like get get accustomed to
the new behaviors um there's incredible
i mean this is this is one of the great
eras for developers
there's so much security that needs to
be figured out there's so much bridging
that needs to be figured out there's so
much capabilities of minting that we
haven't even explored yet i mean this is
probably the most exciting time for a
developer
since probably 2005 678 when the web 2
movement was happening um
so you know
it's funny for me to even think that
developers don't see how big of an
opportunity this this is i think it goes
back to education and execution yeah i
think uh you know you touched on that a
little bit as well one of the other
questions was about how initiatives like
coders hq
are focused on enabling the coding
communities and you know you said
education obviously but
um you know how could they focus on
driving communities towards
you know so what kind of education how
do they shift from
how it currently is to
uh web 3.0
where does it start
it starts with believing that the
opportunity exists
you're not going to spend 50 hours
learning
if you don't think it's there
so
you know i remember when ruby on rails
as the language started catch attention
back in four five six seven trying to
remember exactly the timing
you had to believe that that was a
language that was gonna catch
you know
heat otherwise you weren't gonna stop
coding in php
and then of course it didn't catch as
long term and it evolves and that's just
the game of development right something
stick some things don't but you learn
you know you learn from certain things
and learning that language might have
helped you be stronger at the next thing
i i think it starts with conviction
around the movement is actually
happening
and again
i think the biggest reason so many of
your friends don't see the nft thing or
the blockchain thing is because they're
bringing their internet perspective to
the blockchain
people make jokes like that's so stupid
i'm going to right click and save that's
an internet lingo
that's what we did on the internet
that's not how the black chain works
when people like this is stupid like
who owned like people say the most basic
things like it is much easier for me to
know if you own something on the
blockchain than for me to know if you
own something in real life we can all go
outside right now and take a picture
next to a car put on social media make
pretend it's our car
people do that
you can't do that with an nft i can look
it up in three seconds and see you don't
own it
so what's really fascinating is
is the concept of
are we grasping the opportunity and are
we
learning how to not bring our web 2
development brain to web 3 which is why
so many projects struggled last year
incredible developers
didn't even realize that subconsciously
they didn't understand the pitfalls they
were going to have at mint because they
didn't understand that they didn't
control the server even though it's
decent it's just fascinating to watch
so i think a recognizing the situation
and then b
having the humility to really put in the
work to do it properly
what are the factors that drive your
decision into investing into digital uh
companies i mean you did it you know at
a very early stage like you said with
the wine company and also invested into
tech companies and now you're very
ahead in the uh
web 3.0 world
my
my greatest strength is intuition around
what people are gonna do before they
realize they're gonna do it
that has been my real business gift that
i'm able to
somehow
intuitively understand that you are
going to do this even though you say
you're not going to and i think a lot of
that has to do with
a couple of core beliefs i have which is
a
i don't think humans
understand how much convenience will
always win in the end
that you know that
i remember the blackberry to iphone
debate
so many people never thought they would
get an iphone because they liked the
buttons on the blackberry
but i remember just thinking every day
from day one i'm like but it has the
internet on it
and the internet is more powerful than
touching buttons the internet will beat
the buttons and i think that's how i
think about the consumer blockchain i
already understand
that nfts representing the mundane like
a receipt or a ticket or a bracelet is
going to be better for people they just
don't see it yet
like and so
i you know for
me what i do is first i understand the
consumer truth
people are going to do this
that that's intuition pattern
recognition
my obsession with history
there's a lot of things that help me be
good at it
and then the next thing i do after that
is
i i i invest based on the human being
that's running it i think the reason
that i'll be successful in nft investing
and a lot of people are going to lose
is i don't believe in what a lot of
people accept this truth for example so
many people talk gary this nft
has i i think a lot of you if you are in
this space remember
the last several months i love the road
map
that's why i'm investing and i was like
but that's like a pitch deck
just because you say you're gonna do
something doesn't mean that's a good
reason to invest i learned that lesson
in my career that was a good deck but
they didn't know how to actually run a
company number two gary you don't get it
this is gonna win because of the
community
well the community is only as good as
the people executing the project these
communities are not really built the far
majority on communities they're built on
the fact you're rooting for it because
you bought it and you want it to go up
you're financially incentivized just
like people that bought beanie babies
cared about it to just flip thus beanie
babies died because they're not disney
they're not transformers they're not
marvel where you actually care about the
characters you just bought the beanie
baby to sell the beanie baby which is 99
of the behavior in nfts which is why i
put out content saying 99 of these are
going to fail because i know human
behavior
for me what i do is believe in a human
truth a thesis and then i start looking
for the people that i think are capable
of driving that to a successful outcome
which is
something i don't think people are
spending enough time on in nft land i
mean there are people spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
projects where the founders are
anonymous
the reason there's so many rug pulls is
because people are making bad decisions
because they're in a gold rush and
everybody's so
over focused on making money in 24 hours
that they're going to lose money
you always seem to be one step ahead of
the game
the game right now is 3.0 and blockchain
is there anything else that you're
thinking about or
is on your plate that uh is coming up no
i don't allow myself to
think that way
uh
i have no emotion that tomorrow needs to
be a new playing field
what i do is i spend all my time
absorbing
what humans are doing so that i'm ready
when something has emerged i didn't
force nfts into the lexicon i watched
people and realized nfts were on the
precipice of happening
so for me
i'm just paying attention
but i only get interested when things
are on the precipice of scale
my career when it's looked on when i'm
long gone
will probably be much more of a story of
timing than anything else
i bought ethereum in 2015
and you can find clips of me talking
about in 2017 2018 but they're very far
and few between i bought it i understood
the concept
i watched from afar
and then when i felt that the summer of
2020 was showing me indications because
of top shot and flow because of punks
that something was brewing
then i committed to the time in the
winter to say is it ready and then by
early january february 2021 i'm like oh
my god it's ready then i got very loud
you know it's funny i'm so frantic high
energy loud i i understand my
communication style which i think
confuses people at times to think i
might be a little bit throw against the
wall and see what sticks a lot of people
say you know when someone says something
nice about me like man you've been
really right about stuff i'll always see
a lot of comments i'm like yeah if you
predict 900 things three are going to be
right and i always i and i always and i
always reply to those people i'm like
hey would love to have you show me the
video of what i predicted wrong
i think what i do very well
seems very counter to my energy which is
the following there's a great saying
that a lot of people really believe in
which is
measure twice cut once
i believe that i measure 50 times and
cut once
it's just that after i'm done measuring
50 times and i'm ready i cut loudest
i also feel that because of my intuition
and because of my listening strengths
that i do see things a hair early
i once i sense it and i taste it
i'm so convicted that it's a feeling
that i've known before that i'll put in
the work so fast which allows me to
speak to it earlier i was right about
tick-tock
right i was right about social i was
right about e-commerce and content and
many platforms
and
and it's because i put in the work
and i don't fear being wrong
but i'll be very honest with you the
only reason there's so many people in
this room right now is because i've been
right
right like like and so
i tell you a lot of people like well
gary you're of course your nft project's
doing well you have a huge community i'm
like one that i earned
like all like
i'm fascinated by by that and so
i'm incredibly thoughtful of what comes
out of my mouth i think a lot of you
that have followed me for a long time i
don't say that many things i'm pretty
narrow i have a good knack of saying
them 8 000 different ways
um i may say them in new platforms in
different content formats
but you know to me
i'm 100 sure that the consumer
blockchain is going to matter and i'm
trying to learn and build community and
and more importantly
it is incredibly intoxicating to have
your community benefit from your
observations and so that is
been a beautiful part of this journey
for me
[Music]
you